[Musique]
vendredi soir dernière répétition pour
les désinvolte à la veille des
qualifications
yacine le chorégraphe prodigue ses
derniers conseils sont des bulles à pain
en mode un peu vénère tous accès
d'accord par contre le locking lâchez
vous d'accord je préfère que l'accord
est la plus dense et que technique ça va
les six membres du crew peuvent paraître
désinvolte il n'en est rien
demain ils vont participer au
championnat de france de hip hop pour la
première fois et la tension monte aussi
pour le coach déjà on s'attendait pas à
faire cette compétition en fait et puis
ça s'est fait assez rapidement en très
peu de temps et donc du coup
je suis aussi stressé que voire
peut-être même un peu plus donc mon
petit bébé stress samedi matin les
désinvolte arrive au zénith de la
première heure ils sont inscrits dans la
catégorie ados direction la salle de
répétition et là c'est le choc
ils vont devoir se confronter aux
meilleurs crus de france
le trac se mêle alors à l'excitation
il faut dire que le hachage qui est la
plus grande compétition de hip hop du
pays et le niveau est très élevé 60
équipes venues de toute la france vont
s'affronter dans quatre catégories
différentes catégories les juniors les
ados les adultes est rappellé méga coup
c'est son découpeuse entre cas à
l'incarnation sur scène il compatit tous
pour avoir la chose d'emprunté les
couleurs de la france lors du
championnat du monde cet été aux usa à
phoenix les six meilleurs crus de chaque
catégorie iront en finale le lendemain